championnats du monde de 2016 sur des
modèles tv deuxième partie du tie break
entre donc le champion du monde m'amuse
car sienne et le russe sergey kirdyapkin
donc après un match en 12 parties où il
était à égalité et bien la première
partie du tie-break au carré qui n'avait
les blancs a fini par une partie nulle
dans une espagnole le classique dans la
lignée du match
voilà il n'y a pas eu de surprise donc
on va tout de suite cette deuxième
partie donc c'est du rapide je m'appelle
ainsi pas sûr sur les coûts jeu j'essaie
de me concentrer sur les moments chauds
que je perçois éventuellement et on y va
c'est parti avec arsène eu quatre ou
cinq cahiers 3 encore pareil donc
décidément c'est le grand match la
grande victoire d'aubry lopez à ce
championnat du monde c'est vraiment on
est en plein dedans
à saint jean des cars cavaliers c6 c'est
quand même à rolle alors là ça change
car scène varient voilà alors c'est plus
un style de car c'est long convoi que là
c'est quand même lui qui prend le plus
de d'initiatives allant ce match il
varie fous ces quatre ils retentent pas
le l'espagnol laissait doivent essayer
de perturber car yakine fous ces 5
on est en rapide aussi la fatigue qui
joue du match et il joue aussi mais sur
sur le physique aussi il ya aussi un
aspect sportif mais sur un jeu d'échecs
son match comme ça tous particules un
break petit rock alors ici à noter un
que carson aurait pu jouer le fameux
gambie evans que kasparov a joué
plusieurs fois avec succès et même un
championnat du monde mais battu attendre
là dessus b4 voilà donc c'est tout à
fait jouable
bon il rentre pas là dedans quand même
si du rapido sinon que petit rock café
m6 des trois voies là on rentre on
rentre par coup mrc on risque de rentrer
dans une espagnole quand même un petit
rock a4 a6 voilà les noirs jouent le
coup à six pour remettre leurs fous en a
c'est vrai c'est la même idée que cariat
qui n'a quand il joue à trois pour
mettre fin à deux voilà donc
faut noter ce type de manoeuvre quand on
a comme ça quand on a empêché le fou de
revenir avec des trois bombes et faut
pouvoir le cacher quand même éviter
qu'ils soient s'échanger par un cavalier
ces trois des six vous avez classique un
très connu toro un voilà c'est très
solide face est en jeu le orange le fou
voilà
attention ce fou il est loin on peut
l'oublier sauf qu'ils les superlatifs
voilà on va pouvoir les changer très
vite il faut trois ans plus tard h3 à
trois importants ont repêché absolument
fou g4 si on veut jouer des quatre parce
que le cavaliere 3 faut pas laisser
cloud et c'est lui qui protège des
quatre qui attaquent 5
voilà donc si on peut jouer dès 14 h 30
si on veut pas jouer des quatre on n'est
pas obligé de jouer je crois tout de
suite on peut jouer l'autre cavaliers se
balader et laisser les noirs ce refuge
et quatre ans le chassera plus tard
faire attention à ça voilà qu'avec cette
1re placement même manoeuvre à l'envers
avec les noirs c'est marrant ici car
akin joue avec les noirs la même façon
d'organiser ces pièces noter qu'avec les
blancs voiliers et cavale et c3 rappelez
vous avec les blancs il fait qu'aller c3
qui a lieu 2 kg 3 et là il fait cavalier
huit caves les c6 qu'elle le sait
évoluer à venir angers 6 donc c'est à
noter ses variantes
ayé avec le four en a deux à sept et
avec les modes me le font à deux et donc
il joue la couleur à merci joue un peu
le même placement de pièces des cartes
voilà c'est l'heure c'est bon moment
pour jouer des cas parce que là le pion
et s'acquitte attaqué alors faut pas que
les noirs prennent sans doute sinon ça
laisserait les blancs avec un gros
centre de pions mobile on pourrait jouer
le 5 à tout moment voilà il faut
protéger voilà qu'avec g6 c'est toute
l'idée on protège bien 1,5
on ne lâche pas le centre on ne laisse
pas les blancs ramener une majorité au
centre on tient le centre quel est des
deux c6
qui ne voulaient même coup en fait blanc
ou noir jouent la même partie soit
question le russe fouet fin voilà
maintenant qu'on a joué des quatre noter
que ce fou pour revenir en f1 est pas et
se cacher ou à deux donc c'est notre
façon de faire donc en maintenant f1 bon
me protéger le roi s'est jamais ya deux
cavaliers là quand même ça peut être
menaçants et puis bon ben il garde un
oeil ou six ou sept heures grande
diagonale il peut se passer des choses
par là aussi si les blancs lancent une
attaque à l'aide à 5 pour jouer à celle
qu'ils empêchent un b4 trop rapide à la
forêt fléchir l'on peut jouer b4 quand
même il faut y réfléchir
puis on prend puis on prend et dames ces
deux tranquille vous aussi sont là les
murs finissent leur développement pas de
problème particulier pour car iachini si
calais ces quatre cavaliers protégé par
le fou qui toys oracene petite taille
est un sou sur scène qui en prit comme c
c est normal c le cookie à la fois
protège de 5 protégea simple il est au
naturel
mais c'est simple les échecs des 4 alors
attention car celle là son attaque la
belle dame donc d'où l'idée de laisser
ce fou sur cette diagonale il contrôle
des cazals lda il envoie le envoie le
bois que font les noix attention un coup
comme b6 serez pas un très bon coup
puisque sa bouche le fou les blancs
prendrait part à cinq dans ce cas la b6
il est le fou enfermé et ils vont jouer
faux 3 et vous tomberez ils vont passer
leur pièce avant de se décider à faire
des choses et l'instant dans le fou à
sept îles est bloquée d'art sont propres
pions donc les noirs prennent voilà pour
rester dynamique a problem is prise
et maintenant c'est le qui contre
attaque avec b5 intéressant profite du
fait que en cas de prise prises le
cahier de bouger on peut changer les
dates et avec une finale sans doute
facile à jouer kallio 3 donc ni blanc ne
prennent pas attention les blancs menace
soit fou prend b5 soit à prendre des sel
puisque la dame c7 ici empêche le pian
de reprendre ça serait perdu puis on
prend 1,4 taux prend 1 mais surtout
reprend on active la tour là on rêverait
de pouvoir jouer le four les doubler les
taux ici faire une pression sur le
colonel
on peut aussi venir en a6 avec la tour
attaqué ces six on est protégé par le
fou voilà donc on simple et blanc sont
un tout petit peu mieux la plus d espace
dynamique faut prendre voilà alors
qu'arras keane là se dit bon ok
attention les blancs commencent à être
un peu actif
c'est le moment pour simplifier et pour
simplifier il faut changer maximum de
pièces
donc il prend prendre trois faux prend
tout reprend d'apprendre les noirs ont
simplifié mais il reste avec le problème
sous pillon ici empêche les noirs de
jouer en c5 il faut aussi il est
potentiellement clou et je vais pouvoir
jouer tour c'est un jeu peut faire un
peu le siège de ce pion celui-là est
facile indéfendable pour les blancs sans
doute mais bhl en plus un peu plus d
espace bon celui-là peut être attaqué ou
s'il fait attention quand même un peu
plus tard à noter aussi que les blancs
la paire de fou après les chants fou
prend en cavalier les blancs la paire de
fous pas les noirs et tant qu'il restait
deux pions là et pas de pions et des
pions de l'autre côté
et bien cette paire de fou peut faire
valoir une supériorité sur les pièces
les autres pièces voilà des pions que
d'un côté c'est plus dur car les prend
alors attention les blancs laisser le
pion aux quatre ans prises c'est une
fausse menace regardez c'est simple tour
c'est un attaque c6 les blancs sont
contents d'échangés ce pion contre le
pion si si si c'est possible pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont un pion passer un pion
passé soutenu par une paire de fou c'est
mortel donc c'est un bon échange par
ailleurs en laissant prendre quatre
quand même pris parce qu'ils se disent
vous simplifier au maximum
il peut y avoir une menace aussi de type
c 5 bessane par en bessin et la dame
attaque le cavalier
voyez latéralement lui-même le jouer
tout de suite mais qu'est ce qui se
serait passé d'ailleurs tiens bessane si
tu joues un mécène tout de suite on
aurait sans doute jouer cavalier oui en
c3 pour attaquer la dame puis serait
venue en peut-être en décembre ce
cavalier où on aurait pris ensuite en
bessin et la dame protège le cavalier
possible aussi bref donc tour c'est
d'abord empêche qu il a laissé trois
food et ce n est là qu intéressant
bessèges
voilà avec l'idée ben si tu prends la
dame étant prises mais attention s'ils
ne reprenne la dame 1,4 et emprises
aussi donc que font les blancs ici les
noirs à votre avis ici de seconde
eh ben ils prennent quand même mais ce
faisant
est-ce qu'ils ont oublié la manoeuvre
suivante ils se disent bon c'est bon si
les blancs prennent pour le jeu sur
madame gemplus compter les pions et si
les blancs prennent la dame je reprends
ici j'ai même deux pions plus donc ça
craint quand donc qu'en cas preuve qu
arsène là-dessus grande et c'est très
joli mais kara qui n'a volontairement et
rentrer là-dedans regarder tom 34
superbe
l'idée c'est que si maintenant les noirs
prennent bel adam reste en prise et si
les noirs prennent la tour je prends une
deuxième pièce avec le fou donc j'ai
deux pièces contre la toîle me reste la
paire de fou donc bilan des courses
nouvelle erreur car akin a très bien vu
dans prend on prend et après simplement
dames c'est cette belle et noir 10b
coûte c'est pas grave blessure tu as
peur de fous ici contre ma tour ce qui
en soi est mieux mais j'ai quand même un
pion de plus qui compense et il ya plus
de pions éloigner la donc ce qui fait
que je peux bâtir une forteresse et ça
devrait tenir et il a sans doute raison
d'un premier cinq tombes et 8
forteresse ça veut dire on va serrer les
vis à noter que pour gagner il faut
quand même essayer de soi de gagner une
pièce de plus surtout de faire passer un
pion mais quand on atteint que 3 contre
4 c'est durant même avec une pièce de
plus mais c'est juste de pièces contre
une tour en tour c'est quand même fort
dans des huit meilleures quand même un
petit avantage blanc s'il tient
clairement donc il faut qu'arsène joue
pour le gain d'un b 3 c'est lui qui est
mieux il a réussi obtenu une bonne
finale damak d'amis ici h6 maintenant on
arrive au 30e coude en d5
du coup de manoeuvre ici pour optimiser
le placement des pièces d'un jeu cette
voie là on place la dame au centre vue
sur cinq petites actions sur cette
diagonale on ne sait jamais imaginé
qu'on met un point d 3 on joue h 4 h 5
cas les bouger ces matins à 7 sauf si
sauf si on veut en fuite mais dans ce
cas là on a repoussé le cavalier et on
prend plus d espace 2006 on n'est pas là
on n'y est pas encore j'ai trois un
mauvais coup du blanc seau mieux ils ont
tout leur temps en plus pour mieux la
position pour ses huîtres ward et les
noirs jouent des coudes attentes tour
s'est vite
voilà typiquement ça sert à rien c'est
juste un coup à toi j'ai une forteresse
quoi voilà comment qu'est ce que tu fais
comme tu passes fou des trois tomes c6
d'un médecin il faut garder les dames
sans doute sur les dames c'est très
certainement nul est quand même plus en
plus pour les noirs pour gagner ça faut
qu on se levait tout temps surtout en
rapide en plus on ne peut pas tout
calculé en précision faux et 4 dames 6
damage 5 voilà on évite échange des
dames carillo 7
dame prend 5 à les blancs se décide à
prendre le pian e5
ici les noirs ont laissé faire pour
échanger les dames en se disant mais ma
forteresse elle tient aussi à trois
contre trois qu'elle les prend ce qui
sans doute vrai qu'aller des jets six
mois la cage et 6 attention attaque le
cavalier en cas de f4 calais prend puis
on prend tout reprend et et j'ai gagné
un pion au passage donc fou prend et
maintenant tout reconquérir voilà la
paire de fou contre tout rebond c'est
sans doute nul ici avec 3 points contre
3 f6 focale jouer les deux rouages suite
attention le roi quand même noir est un
peu passif il ya quand même les cases
blanches un peu faible donc on peut
s'imaginer qu'il payera d'etel sait pas
lesquels mais c'est du rapide il peut se
passer n'importe quoi ou trois tours des
5 fu g6 voulait 6 jean ferme un peu le
roi noir
je mets mes pièces là où il faut
j'avance mon roi tu veux gagner il faut
que mon roi soit proche
voilà j'avance le pion à noter ici lien
cette belle chaîne de pure ont protégé
par le fou tout ça est ce ce soutien on
est quatre ou cinq ans et quatre fous
des 4 3 5 pouces et celle les blancs ici
essaye de jouer contre la tour de passer
le roi était là il met ses scènes
puissante pour passer le roi ensuite on
peut venir des 6 et on a avancé le juan
encore et demi on va avancer avec son
roi le roi des cinq dessins 3d si ça y
est on y est duracell on commence à
avoir peur pour le noir quand même la
faute 3
100 au f4 attaque la tour
c'est fou des trois manoeuvres de fouet
tout s'est compliqué il ya aussi la
pendule qui jouent et joueront pas
beaucoup de temps parfois ils jouent des
coudes juste pour gagner un peu quelques
secondes à la pendule puisque à chaque
coup et un petit rajout de temps pour
monter ça aussi tour à cette voie la
torah serait de bon pourquoi pas en 6
voiles alors le roi veut aller angers 6
de manière à faire pression sur g7 ce
genre de choses dont b757 voyez les
noirs attendent tous ces deux pourquoi
pas ont pu faire aussi un petit échec
comme ces 4 1 pour pas perdre de temps
vont tomber cette ag si ça y est on y
est voilà un projet 6 alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec saab a priori pas
grand chose le truc c'est la pression
place bien les fous quand éloigne le roi
en faisant échec et cetera
on pourrait envisager de pousser les
pions peut-être sacrifier comme un fou
contre les pions et puis avec un fouet
deux pions passé on gagne contre une
tour voilà c'est ce genre de chose qui
peut y arriver attention attention les
noirs sont quand même son passif y sont
obligés de doigts ça doit pouvoir tenir
mais en étant précis au f5 pour preuve
deux a ici donc ici attention tout son
tour b2dix belle et blanc ont laissé
prendre
ici le pion pour continuer à leur
attaque après fou et cinq tours prend b2
dit qu'est-ce qu'il va pas regarder faut
six échecs maintenant que font les noirs
sirois f8 fou des six échecs 3,8 boum je
prends j'essaie tout tombe alors
attention appréciée au moins un pion
passé suffit que j'en ai qu'un les deux
foules à la tour sera obligée de se
sacrifier
donc il avec le pion qui restent à 100
gagnant donc là le roi est obligé
d'aller à schwyz
il est quasiment rien des îles et patins
il peut plus bouger un échec et les
matelas bon on peut pas il est bien
solide et fait attention attention faut
des six très bon coup autour d'eux et or
l'a sans doute ici car ce n a raté un
coup très fort ici ils le voient pas il
peut jouer ici le coup je vous montre un
petit peu
bref cette voie là qu'avaient les
rebonds en direct la croyance est
maintenant hors qui va presque réussir
ajoute à tout à l'heure
bref cette idée mais je protège ici
j'empêche la tour de revenir
je menace fouet fuite ah oui vous avez
fait avec ramassage des pions blancs et
c'est pas simple si les noirs attaque le
pion ici j'ai trois on peut jouer g4 et
le pire est protégé par le fou il ya
toujours des fuites qui menacent donc
c'est pas simplement bon peut-être ça
tient quand même un ici les noirs pour y
jouer par exemple un coup comme bats
toujours par un coup d'attentes tourbe
et deux pour essayer enfin coup
d'attendre groupe défense procès devait
tomber cet échec et dire au roi soit tu
mets fou
le set est un peu coincé soit qu'est ce
que tu fais quoi
hélas les plantes pourrait jouer fouet
fuite par exemple attaque le pion
fissette et sur tourbe et cet échec
simplement maintenant revenir ou g6 et
la tour le roi est coincé et la tour est
obligé de rester sur la septième sous
peine de se prendre vous projet cet
échec suivi d'un massage d'occasion tous
les pions hélas les noirs sont en danger
là le seul coup semble-t-il cette
position je vous passe les détails c'est
on peut pas analyser sa frappe et c'est
du rapide
on va parler ça tous les coups mais
imaginons que les blancs jouent ici le
meilleur coup donc c'est sans doute f5
il n'y a pas de coût pour les poulets
noir ou alors un coup d'oeil imaginons
coûte tout retient les imagine un coude
attentes hi hop tour à 7,6 regardez
regardez regardez
pour terminer champion la tour ne
protège plus g7
en fait on a intercepté l'action de la
tour et aux menaces faut prendre j'ai
cet échec et mat
ça craint donc ici pour empêcher ça les
noirs peuvent tenter ici au lieu de
faire tour à 7
il joue f5
voilà et ici les blancs auraient pu
continuer d'améliorer leur position par
exemple par tous et c'est alors là est
ce que fout et 7 ne marche pas parce que
il y aura échec mois là on joue à 100
c'est pas on s'en fout du plan c'est
pour pouvoir jouer tourbe et 6 échecs en
cas de feu 7
il faut fc tours b 6 échecs le roi est
obligé de partir donc ici par exemple
poussé celle qu avec une position
vraiment intéressante
le fou maintenant on va pouvoir même
venir ici on va pouvoir prendre ce pion
f5 et on va pouvoir après peut-être
pousser les pions voilà avec eux sans
doute des chances de gagner ici
peut-être bon c'est pas sûr pour
l'analyser stand état on va pas le faire
tours 2 donc ici fauché quatre attaques
latour 2.895 continuer les manoeuvres au
g8 je vous passe les détails
regardez pas ce que ça va bouger quand
même pas mal tour 3 koubéens je suis dit
travail car c'est un travail au corps
wave cette tourbe et 3,4 le fou fou et 4
encore en attaque nos forces et 3g cadre
là c'est l'heure pour les blancs il
essaye maintenant de percer la défense
noire tour c6 fouet fuite attention
attention attention c'est un attaque
c'est un peu la même que tout à l'heure
un emmy dévoile à tour c'est cet échec
et roger 6 voilà on obtient une position
qui semblable quand même à ce qu'on a vu
voilà que font les fonds et noirs ici
roger huit attaques l'oeuf ou la poule b
4 alors peut-être ici voilà d'où le sou
des 6 ou sinon c'est pareil
foulée six attaques le fou et l'a trouvé
cette regarder le problème c'est que il
aurait pu retrouver retourner à une
opposition mardi six personnes rate
regard des foules six échecs maintenant
la même variante pour ça que c'est
intéressant à regarder un petit peu il
le voit pas car scène ça on est rapide
il doit y rester 30 sous on a un bon moi
je suis est maintenant au regard des
fouilles suite
et quelle est la menace est toujours là
même fou fouet cette menace matt
d'accord et les noirs sont donc obligés
de jouer f5 avec l'idée si je surfais
vii tour b6 toujours échec mais là c'est
pas la même en a joué g4 on prend du
plomb voyez ici premier pion car s'ils
ne voient pas de cette variante est là
que font les noirs menace menace f6 f6
puis on prend fauves 7 et le pion
empêche l'échec de la tour c'est seimat
en g7 en fait on le
on peut matériel et de fou quoi c'est ça
qui est fou c'est le cas de le dire
imaginons que les noirs donc jouer le
seul coup là où un des rares coups à les
tours ces sept on va jouer pour ses sets
maintenant regardez f6 menace matin mena
ce pion projet c'est tout reprend fou
prend mat
il faut donc prendre le pion voilà et
maintenant tout simplement faux et
peut-être suffi voilà fouet cette menace
match tranquillement donc les noirs sont
obligés de sacrifier la tour contre le
fou il reste le fou de cases noires qui
ont donc qui permet d'arrêter le pion va
gober tout à noter que la le pion va
bien pouvoir faire dame
il nous reste le bon fou et ça gagne
avec hershey ne voit pas incroyable
tomber cette peut-être il va peut-être
raté son championnat du monde à cause de
cette l'a pas vu fou aux six échecs là
tu gagnes la partie food et 6,3 schmitt
fouet fuite
ouais c'est pas tout à fait la même moi
j'évite voilà parce que les noirs
peuvent attaquer le fou fois trois
rouages suite
pardon est ici maintenant fou aux six
ans se dit c'est presque la même
on menace fouet fuite mais non c'est
double c'est un honneur de jouer tour b6
et voilà c'est pas la même on n'a pas le
temps
pour jouer vous êtes 7 mai sur fond f7
peut-être f5 échec tout simplement oui
c'est d'ailleurs dangereux imaginons que
l'on fasse software 7 ici voilà f5 échec
voilà de manière à libérer très
important les échecs ici sinon ce fait
mater comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure
hélas les noirs les blancs ne peuvent
pas prendre un f5 avec le roi ils sont
en échec de la tour parce qu'ils
auraient tous réussissent échec ramasse
le fou ils sont obligés de venir en 5 et
aura des c'est plus du tout la même
sk je fis la table eh oui donc ça
devient beaucoup plus compliqué donc
c'est plus du tout la même partie et
c'est donc c'est pas exactement la même
variante heureusement qu'il a trouvé le
tour b 6e khanaqinne ici
bref cette mais là ils se trompent la
carcel il semblait les pinceaux tomber
cet échec il fait fou aux 7,7 il a vu
trop tard qu'il a raté la variante il
essaie de retrouver la position n'y
arrive pas et la carabine joué un très
bon coup h5 voilà qui va simplifier la
position les blancs sont quasiment
obligée de prendre s'ils prennent pas
bon on peut prendre du plan par exemple
j'essaie puis on prend on est obligé de
reprendre du pian puisque le foot louer
et le pion à chf il a donc les blancs et
rouges le rattraper le lait noir
n'auront plus de problème je prends h5
f5 à la hep cei qu avec l'idée paraît on
libère la sixième la sixième rang j'ai
donc on peut faire des échecs on enlève
tous les problèmes fauve 5 et l'a
regardé superbe car yakine magnifique
tour prend 1 cet échec voilà
et oui c'est pas la même parce que là
cette faune dans le foot cases blanches
ses deux pions censure h
on peut pas les faire dame / noir il
suffit pour les noirs de pabx ou gestion
alors après on peut se dire mais
peut-être que les blancs on peut forcer
les noirs bouge espion mais en fait on
va voir que ça sape on peut pas
reprendre 7 mais fallait il fallait le
calcul est quand même alors mes talents
roi g8
sous des trois rois fuite il faudrait
forcer les noirs bouge espion parce que
ces documents peuvent pas gagner la
voilà on peut pas encore et faire dès
qu'on avance ses prix et l'autre pied on
peut pas aller à dame et on a on est
sûrs aux cases noires et le futur classe
blanche comprend jamais empêché le
sortir le roi et mais si on force les
noirs à bouger le pion on prend le
problème c'est que pour le forcer il
faut tenir la fois cette case et celle
ci or pour tenir cette cause celle-ci
faut que ce soit le roi puisque le foot
tient l'autre case le foot j'aime case
le roi doit être son ange et si son avis
est ce qui fait quand on bouge le pion
quelle que soit la reprise le roi risque
d'être pas tu risques je suis pas sûr
même si si les pattes il n'est pas parce
que si on reprend du roi et demandant
les deux mauvais pions donc si on
reprendre et on peut pas jamais
reprendre du pian sans laisser le roi
adverse pas tout bref 8
voilà j'essaie menant tranquillement
mais pourquoi mais parce qu'on n'est pas
tu si les blancs prennent le pion ses
pattes
si les blues prennent pas le nom vont
simplement prendre le pion h4 et peu
importe il repère de ce brillant ce pion
là ne peut pas aller à dame c'est ça le
leader après h3g 6 c'est pat jolie
pattes quand même championne du monde
serra voilà qu arsène a raté le guen on
l'a vu mais bon c'était vraiment la fin
de la partie c'est du rapide et voilà il
n'a pas vu il faut aussi chez check
d'ailleurs avec une grande gagnante
voilà donc attention car à qui n'est
passé pas loin de la correctionnelle
donc rendez vous pour la prochaine juste
après la troisième partie de ceux des
partages après ces deux parties deux
premières parties nulles mais on l'a vu
car scène à deux doigts de marquer un
point décisif ont donc à tout de suite
pour la pour la troisième